do have big news about this fund how
difficult was it to raise the money and
where do you plan on spending it so we
were fortunate Jennifer Vaughn said and
I announced the fund a year ago our plan
was phase one found her funded which we
did we had about a dozen investments and
when that happened we said okay now time
to raise a fund so that we can build a
next generation firm hire people and to
be honest we were very fortunate I think
it was a combination of between the two
of us having 15 plus your track records
each with six IPOs 26 mas and then we
had a dozen portfolio companies that
could look at and was fairly
straightforward and we were fortunate to
you know hit the top end or exceed the
top end of our target range now yeah I
remember both of you came on the show to
talk about it when you started the firm
and you know it's it's a shame that you
guys are the rarity here in Silicon
Valley and that's one thing that suit
kinder brought to the floor in the in in
a letter that you wrote on Rico this
week talking about this issue of women
in technology but you had a sort of a
different take on it so you can do it I
want to read a quote from your letter
where you said all tech entrepreneurs
not just female ones encounter bias be a
gender age or business model people make
judgments about us as we pitch our
vision long before we have data but as a
startup community our most universal
bias is toward possibility what do you
mean by that it's a big argument and we
don't have a ton of course no it's it's
very simple look at the end of the day
our own data showed in the letter the
women faced discrimination and bias by
the way sixty-seven percent of women
tech founders we surveyed said that they
encounter that but when you try and
change any ecosystem right particularly
ones in the valley you start with what's
possible in fact entrepreneurship
thrives on the idea of possibility
that's true so yes have we faced by us
yes have men faced buyers who are older
than you know the young 22 year old
founder they have to the point is if we
want to make progress on this issue we
do actually need to showcase what's
possible the return to possibility is
one of the ways in fact to enable change
and so it is important to amplify what's
possible and the women entrepreneurs
that are succeeding every day in the
valley now Teresa you you worked at
Excel part
for a very long time where there are a
lot of male partners was it different
are more difficult to raise money as a
woman going out on your own with
Jennifer I think it's certainly
different to be a first-time fun versus
you know raising fund 9 10 11 12 but as
I said we were really fortunate to have
great support first from the
entrepreneurial community in terms of
finding many great opportunities to
invest in including companies like Vita
health which definitely Nia's co-founded
or X abeam in the security space and
then as a result we were able to have
great support from the investor
community including investor
entrepreneurs I should mention sue
kinder is actually an investor in an
aspect as well what did you guys see in
the Ellen Pao trial sukhendu so I think
we saw a couple of things number one I
think the fact that Ellen was brave
enough to step out on an issue like
discrimination in and of itself elevated
the conversation and I think there's no
doubt that Ellen pals you know stepping
forward regardless of the outcome bought
into the water cooler conversation
between men and women you know what is
really happening and I think bought to
the for the idea of unconscious bias for
sure Teresa yeah you know I think that
the unconscious bias piece is a big part
of it what it really highlights is the
importance of culture and how culture is
actually important in people's ability
to succeed or not succeed in a
particular environment and I think
having the culture discussion is
important and I think that's why what
sue kinder wrote in choose possibility
is important for two reasons one is I've
always said the fastest way to make
change is to start something new and
then the second thing is it brings a
positive narrative of people who are
succeeding and killing it and starting
things in Silicon